WHY DO YOU THINK BROTHERS DON'T
SEE UFOs.
>> IT'S AN INTERESTING FACT.
YEAH, YEAH, THEY DON'T-- .
>> Larry: MY THEORY IS WE
HAVE A BLOCK AGAINST SHIPS
THAT MIGHT TAKE US --
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> Larry: I THINK WE HAVE A
BLOCK, RIGHT.
I THINK IT'S A BLOCK.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Larry: I'M JUST SAYING.
>> THAT HADN'T OCCURRED TO
ME THAT-- WELL, IT'S JUST
MOST BLACK FOLK LIVE IN
CITIES AND ALIENS HAVE THIS
SHALL DID --.
>> Larry: I LOVE THERE IS A
SCIENTIFIC REASON.
>> BUT WAIT A MINUTE.
MOST OF THE UNITED STATES
LIVE IN DENSELY POPULATED
CITIES.
AND ALIENS THAT VISIT US
TEND TO BE SHY AND ONLY
VISIT PLACES WHERE THERE ARE
HARDLY ANY PEOPLE.
THAT MINIMIZE THE EYE
WITNESSES WHO CAN ACCOUNT
FOR IT, SO THIS IS HOW YOU
GET THE STATISTICS OF BLACK
FOLK NOT SEEING ALIENS.
>> Larry: ALL RIGHT, VERY
GOOD.